(dramatic music)
(chewing)
- How long would you say is like,
an appropriate amount of time
before I can go get seconds?
- I would say like one to two hours.
- No.
- Yeah I mean I went to a
wedding a few months ago,
and I didn't get food
for ever, it was torture.
- Just to be courteous, or?
- No, I just didn't wanna draw
too much attention to myself.
I technically wasn't
invited to that wedding.
- Well I'm hungry, and you know what?
Alex invited me to have
some of his birthday pizza,
so I'm gonna have some, alright?
Yeah, hey Alex!
- I don't know, one time I
went to this birthday party,
and I didn't get my
hands on a piece of cake
until pretty much everyone had left.
And it was off of, you
know, left over plates.
- Okay, how many people
here even got pizza?
One, two, three. There's only six slices.
That's not enough pizza!
- Just go for it Steven,
you're obviously hungry.
- Yeah?
You know what, you're right.
I shouldn't have to wait to get seconds.
I'ma get some.
(screeching)
(intense music)
Woo, worth it.
- Hey.
- [Steven] Yo, hey.
- Do you guys know who ate all the pizza?
- Mhm, me and a few
other people finished it.
Thanks Alex!
- Dude, why are you thanking him?
- It's uh, it's his birthday pizza.
- Dude, his birthday was three months ago.
That was my pizza.
(exhaling sharply)
- Alex, what the heck?
Let me get you another
pizza, is that okay?
- Sure.
- Okay.
- That guy.
- Right?
- So I'm going to a bar mitzvah
this weekend, wanna come?
- Yeah, okay.